[موسيقى]
هناك اسئله الحقيقه حول الموعد الانتخابي
المقبل ونحن نعلم ان ولايه الرئيس قيس
سعيد تنتهي في اكتوبر من عام 2024 كما
اوضحت الهيئه المستقله للانتخابات في هذه
الاثناء نرى اصوات متعاليه من معرضين
الرئيس والبرلمان تؤكد ان تلك الانتخابات
لن تجري ما الذي تملكونه من معطيات
ومعلومات عن هذا الملف
معرفه عن السيد الرئيس هو انه استاذ قانون
دستوري
ويحترم القانون ويحترم الاجل وكل المواعيد
التي اعلن على في السابق احترم اجالها ولا
ارى موجب لعدم احترام الاجل الانتخابات في
المستقبل واعتقد وانه سيكون دائما على
وعده في احترام هذه الاجيال الانتخابيه
ماذا عن المحكمه الدستوريه والجدل القائم
بشانها
الدستوريه مساله بسيطه جدا سوف يعرض
القانون الاساسي المنظم للمحكمه الدستوريه
على المجلس التشريعي
وسيكون من اولويات العمل التشريعي عندما
يقع عرض هذا القانون وعند المصادقه عليه
سنه تلتئم المحكمه الدستوريه لاننا مكونات
المحكمه الدستوريه نظمها الدستور وهي
تتكون من الاغذيه الثلاث القضاء العادي
والقضاء الاداري والقضاء المالي وعن كل
قضايا يعني هناك ثلاثه قضات برتبه رؤساء
دوائر
لدى محكمه التعقيب يعني سرق لدى محكمه
النقد او البراما او محكمه التمييز
وبالتالي تقريبا الاشخاص الان معروفين
ننتظر فقط يعني
النظر في القانون الاساسي الذي سيعرض في
القريب العاجل على مجلس النواب